With DARPA support, we have
developed an interactive system
for the efficient inspection
of multiple videos recorded
along spatially similar
paths but at different times.
The system enables a
human sequence analyst
to detect differences
between the two videos.
The system is based on
the techniques described
in the paper "Video Matching"
by Peter Sand and Seth Teller,
which appeared in the
proceedings of SIGGRAPH 2004.
The idea is to determine the
frame of the second video that
is visually closest to each
frame of the primary video.
This secondary frame
is then warped to match
the primary frame
and the difference
between the two frames is
generated as a false color
image.
The sequence analyst can
see at a glance which parts
of the scene have changed.
With the addition of
reference tags to each video,
we can search for matching
frames far more efficiently
and can flag regions
where differences
exist in a map-based interface.
This interface quickly
tells the sequence analyst
which regions of the
map contain areas
in which the system detected
a substantial difference
in the scene between the times
that the primary and secondary
videos were acquired.
Here is an example of a clear
difference found by our system.
The system saw that these trash
cans in the secondary video
were not present when the
primary video was recorded.
It flagged this segment
as a difference,
and the trash cans
appear clearly
in the difference video.
One of the strengths
of our system
is that it can detect
differences that may easily
escape a human observer.
In this video, the system
detected two people
walking down some train tracks.
It is hard to perceive the
people by eye even when
comparing the secondary
video to the primary video.
But the system detected it and
a look at the difference video
shows the two people clearly.
The system can also
match videos recorded
in largely featureless
environments such as deserts.
In this example, a
simulated explosive device
was buried near a fence.
Even in this largely
homogeneous video,
the system can still
spot the difference
as shown in the
difference video.
The current system
is only a prototype.
It serves as a proof of concept
that a system based on computer
vision techniques can perform
useful change detection
across long video
sequences acquired
in a variety of environments.